[Musique]
sur le bord de la white pays caché au
creux des montagnes le village du walk
of ne compte que 46 habitants dont
quatre enfants
c'est ici qu'est grandi clé football
ce trio son père lui a transmis sa
passion pour la pêche
jusqu'à 33 ans il était le capitaine du
lait du small 2 le père de deux enfants
s'est ensuite réorienter dans le secteur
de la restauration avant de faire le
saut en politique
à 51 ans
costume pays central notre dame est la
deuxième plus grande circonscription de
la province après labrador
deux mois avant le déclenchement de la
campagne électorale le candidat allait
déjà de porte en porte dans l'espoir
d'être élu
il a frappé à dix mille portes au cours
de l'été dans ciels de desmond crise
cliff lee smolin lui a demandé d'être
bénévole pour lui sur l'île fogo
seacliff heureusement elle était
inconnue dans la sphère publique c'est
tout le contraire qu'on soit opposant
libéral scott simms a été présentateur
du est présent sur la scène fédérale
depuis 2004 il a été battu par 264 voix
du corps d'anna nicole sol comme hawaii
qu'ovh sur les 26 électeurs qui se sont
rendus aux urnes le 20 septembre 25 ont
voté pour que les frites morts
le dernier pêcheur ce village à voter
pour lui comme plusieurs pêcheurs ses
attentes envers son nouveau député sont
immenses
et l'un de ses principaux objectifs
comme nouveau député inciter le
gouvernement à intensifier la chasse aux
phoques et commercialiser ses produits à
plus grande échelle
selon lui il faut convaincre des pays
qui ont décidé d'interdire l'importation
des produits du phoque à revenir sur
leur position il croit également que le
gouvernement canadien est trop influencé
par les groupes environnementaux du
match contrôles
inopinés c'est justement du phoque
braisé qui est servi chez kit kat un
chasseur de la cie qui le reçoit pour le
souper de l'action de grâce
pour lui nul doute que la prochaine
élection amènera au pouvoir un premier
ministre conservateur une étape cruciale
si le qu'ici comme ailleurs la viande de
phoque deviennent plus présente dans les
assiettes ici mme montembeault radio
canada la cie